this is jonathan ferguson the keeper of
firearms and artillery at the royal
army's museum in the uk
which houses a collection of thousands
of iconic weapons from throughout
history
and on this bonus episode jonathan
discusses the basics of a modern day
snipe rifle
its historical definition and how they
work or
don't work in video games make sure to
subscribe for more videos featuring
jonathan and if you'd like to help out
the royal armies museum and continue to
support jonathan's work
check out the links in the description
of this video right over to jonathan
it's easy enough to define what one is
now i think
maybe which is um a
highly accurized rifle firing a
cartridge of
a certain power level that enables you
to reach out to
really quite extreme ranges so beyond
800 meters
up to maybe even 2 000 meters with some
sort of an optical
sight with high magnification 12 power
20 power something like that
so that you can even identify your
target
at long range and then so that you can
put
a reticle on them put in all of the data
that you need to
the right clicks onto your scope to land
a precision
single shot at very long range that's in
essence what a sniper rifle
has to do and so it means that they
they're relatively easy
to define and they're operated in a team
of
two typically you might be on your own
but typically a team of two
a spotter to identify targets as to what
that means for
the actual weapon well traditionally
it's been a
custom set up if not custom made
bolt action rifle
typically with a magazine low capacity
five rounds maybe
and you might even single load it
because you're so far away and you have
people protecting you snipers will
typically carry a second
primary weapon effectively or their
secondary weapon will be something like
an assault rifle or
perhaps a sub-machine gun increasingly
complicating matters a bit
is the are improvements in
semi-automatic
weapons they're so good now that you can
get semi-automatic rifles that are just
as accurate
as bolt action rifles and so those are
taking over now
um there's less and less reason to go
for a bolt action
[Music]
so we're fairly comfortable with what a
modern sniper rifle is
but the definition changes over
time and space so the dragon of
the svd is still called a sniper rifle
even though even in the soviet and then
later the russian and other armies
it was always treated as what we would
call in the west a designated marksman's
rifle
which is something that is typically
semi-automatic not bolt action
it might fire the same sort of cartridge
as a sniper rifle it'll probably have a
reduced power optical sight so not 20
power more like
six power something like that or four
even and so different
different countries terminology factors
in here and that actually ties up with
what sniper rifles
or what sniper rifle used to mean which
was
really any rifle used for sniping i'm
doing a lot of air quotes here because
terminology changes over time so we know
what a sniper is today
very highly drained all of that but a
sniper
in its original meaning as it was
originally coined
in like the 19th century sniping and a
sniper could be anyone
with a rifle anyone taking a pot shot
essentially
so just a a normal rifleman could act as
a sniper
by picking out an individual target and
taking careful aim shots at them
the rifle wouldn't be a sniper rifle
they wouldn't be a trained sniper
the first time in history we get proper
trained snipers
and we start to see modifications to the
rifles
is the first world war britain france
germany
all of the major powers start to look at
making more of a science out of sniping
so instead of just oh good old alf he's
good with an smle
get him on that firing point those guys
evolve into
the designated marksmen later on um but
some of them the really skilled ones
would go away to a sniper school
and have weeks of training and be given
a known
accurate rifle so it'd be just like
alpha's smle
but it would be one that had been
selected from the factory
as especially accurate and tested and
you knew that it would
create a good group at a given distance
speaking of distance we're talking here
about relatively close ranges
probably not much more than standard
infantry engagement ranges so 300
maybe meters yards doesn't really matter
these these guys were
by 1918 highly trained experienced
skilled
um they some of them were hunters in
civilian life
some of them even brought their own
rifles they invented the ghillie suit
to camouflage themselves that kind of
thing and then as
as militaries tend to do after the first
world war we don't need that anymore we
get rid of the sniper schools but we
certainly did in britain
and we have to relearn it all again in
world war ii second world war
by 1918 we'd invented specialist sniper
versions of those
standard infantry rifles so they had
scope mounts
and they had telescopic sights but they
were very low magnification
so three three and a half power what we
would now regard
as not just a designated marksman site
but a standard infantry rifle
site and the exceptional guys would be
the snipers of today snipers and
spotters so it's a real evolution
over 100 years there were snipers before
there were sharp shooters who were
highly skilled
we had the rifle regiment in the uk
famously the american riflemen were
highly skilled in the war of
independence so
it's not that we haven't always had
snipers
but as a dedicated role and especially
as a specialized weapon
the first time you can really say we
have snipers and sniper rifles
is during the first world war as to
the sniper rifle in its video game
incarnations over time i think it's been
perhaps more successful
than more difficult to handle categories
i think it's easy to
get your head around something that's
very slow firing
very powerful very accurate and it has a
you know this different interface
probably the very earliest times games
like hostages even
you would get a depiction of the scope
so probably a black screen or maybe just
superimposed over
your view and so i think games generally
have an easier time of it than
more nuanced classes of weapons like
machine guns submachine guns rifles
the implementation is what isn't always
successful draw distance is a huge thing
yeah
very few games early on had really good
draw distance
in any meaningful way that would allow
you to exploit the relative advantage of
having a sniper rifle
your standard rifle is capable out to
the maximum effective range of the
game's graphics engine
so the sniper rifle doesn't really do
anything unless you make it
more powerful what the scope the
representation of a scope lets you do is
get right up to that
maximum distance within within the
engine but again you need you need
sufficient graphics
horsepower to be able to make that work
and even in games like battlefield
we see that for partly for gameplay
reasons not just graphical
reasons you have to scale down the
effective range of a sniper rifle
you end up with exaggerated bullet drop
so i think i think broadly if we're
taking um the video game
as a pantheon um the sniper rifle is
usually quite a distinct
thing having said that only
only a certain selection of games really
try and nail the
the experience of being a sniper in
terms of
lying in shrubs for hours on end
which which no game does but um some
kind of get
part way there like famously the sniper
elite series you know if you want to
role play a sniper
and shoot a sniper rifle that pretty
much replicates
a real one you can do that but your your
typical
mainstream aaa first person shooter
can't really do justice to the sniper
rifle but i think that's more to do
with the limitations of gameplay and if
we go far enough back
the limitations of software
inevitably because games are trying to
replicate
or at least look like reality pulling it
off is difficult
so this is this is how we end up with
the infamous
call of duty effect of quick scoping
no scoping where you can just gain the
mechanics
of what's going on in a way that's just
not possible with a real gun
or or even i guess in like a vr
representation of a sniper rifle
you've got to sort of semi-physically
bring that up to your eye and align the
put the crosshair on the target
potentially compensate for bullet drop
and windage and all that
and then pull the trigger whereas your
more high-energy first-person shooter
you're able to just
peel back the or draw back the curtains
of
the the veneer of realism and just treat
it like a super powerful one-shot
gun it doesn't really matter that it's a
sniper rifle if you're
really good you can literally just you
know well quick scope i think we all
will know how frustrating it is when
when people employ that strategy it's
not so much the the
that sniper rifles fail as a class of
weapon in video games
it's really the implementation that
varies quite a bit if somebody is in
concealment
800 meters away or more um
and knows exactly where you are knows
the wind speed and direction
knows all the data to dial into their
scope
they can take you out without you ever
knowing
that they were there that's a tremendous
problem for
player frustration and enjoyment in a
game
of course to try to compensate for that
well there are various
sort of mechanics you can implement of
course perks that make it easier to
detect snipers
and the big one is of course scope glint
which is one of those game mechanics
that's based on something real
if you have a look at the front of
various scopes on sniper rifles
some of them have a sort of a honeycomb
grille and that's what's called a kill
flash
and that prevents the direct reflection
of sunlight
off your very large shiny lens
it's sort of effective it's almost like
a silencer for light it sort of baffles
the um
the incoming beams of light and
redirects them
scatters them off essentially um there
are other ways to avoid
um scope glint in real life placing
foliage in front of you
positioning yourself just like just like
a photographer so that
the light isn't causing that flash in
practical terms i mean i'm not a sniper
i'm not trying to train military person
i don't know how big of a problem
scope glint is it's clearly a problem or
they wouldn't wouldn't have invented the
kill flash but there are various ways
around it
now what we see in computer games is
like most features of real life
it's greatly exaggerated so you end up
with this insane
million candle power uh beam of light
that may as well be an arrow on the hud
saying
here's the sniper shoot back um but even
a really really
quite realistic series like sniper elite
does include
um a scope link because you've got to
have some parity you've got to be able
to fight back you know you are typically
one man against however many
enemies including enemy snipers and just
like the movies do you have to
exaggerate certain things
to make something enjoyable if you'd
like to support jonathan and the work at
the royal armouries check out the links
in the description where you can donate
become a member pick up jonathan's new
book or subscribe to the royal armories
themselves
thank you so much for watching
you